I have to say out of all my years
working with food this is the most
bizarre thing I have ever held hello and
welcome back to another episode of
edible history
I'm your host Hannah Hart here to talk
to you about tasty foods as we travel
through time a hamburger the American
pride and joy but how American is it
really has a hamburger always been a
fast-food is a hamburger even from
Hamburg and why is it called a hamburger
when there's no ham in it all these
questions have answers but I don't know
them so we're gonna get those answers
from somebody else please join me in
welcoming hamburger professor himself
David Michaels hi David thank you so
much for joining us so let's start with
the basics first things first
why is it called the hamburger when
there's no ham strips of beef they were
basically put together with breadcrumbs
and seasons and salt it was meant to be
in Texas as we know it today
Dinah Bay is why baked sourdough bread
between the so the hamburger is a pretty
American invention but if we're focusing
on the meat patties specifically I mean
how far back have people been mincing
meat with various seasonings about a
dish of ground meat called Karen and it
came about the demand the street food in
that particular region so it always was
kind of a grab-and-go food either way
it's only modern times that have turned
the meat patty into something that has
bread and all you know all the food
groups together frankly I'm excited to
go take a crack at making this Roman
thing
[Music]
so today we're gonna be making the
oldest meat patty recipe known to man
the origin of all meat patties beef a
liter is sucia almond Tata the recipe
we're making today comes from the
daybreak Hokie Nadia which is the art of
cooking and is the oldest known cookbook
to date the Alicia is Tasya omen Tata is
made of pork hearts of winter wheat wine
pepper broth berries crushed nuts and
call so people have been gabbing about
how much they love food since way back
in the day Wow the first step is to turn
my pork meat into pulp okay step number
one cover these puppies
you know not a protip don't shut your
eyes when you're cutting me just in
general okay hey this kind of looks like
a patty to me I think that that is great
and I definitely don't have to do it two
more times okay
[Music]
they say don't play with your food and I
say doesn't this look like a brain
zoonotic creation will live so we
survived mincing our meat now we're
gonna transfer it into this bowl I'm
gonna take these gloves off wash my
hands and then come back for more next
we're gonna take our pulpy pork and
grind it together with hearts of winter
wheat now because this recipe is yield
it doesn't actually call for portioning
everything is to taste but obviously
we're working with raw meat so I'm not
gonna be doing any tasting we're gonna
be doing a lot of guessing here and
that's really all history is now I don't
think they had meat grinders so I think
we're gonna have to grind the meat
together with this by hand that looks
like a hearty portion of meat flesh part
of winter wheat now pummel your pulp so
the heart of winter wheat will be acting
as our binding agent whoa I'm not gonna
lie this grinds beautifully
[Music]
now that I'm done winding the pork
together with the hearts of winter wheat
I'm gonna mix it all back together
together together together now I think
this looks pretty moist but the recipe
Fell's us to dilute it with wine and I
can't help but wonder if that's because
they'll we're always working with like
the freshest meat Wow
the hearts of winter wheat has absorbed
the wine instantly
so we're gonna take some fresh peppers
grind them up along with the pepper the
recipe also calls for adding broth now
our best guess is by broth they meant
what is more similar to fish sauce now
to add our crushed berries
yum nice and chunky and vaguely dirty
looking next crush pine nuts
voila the next step I've been dreading
the most the recipe tells us to shape
the forcemeat into small roles if you
know what they mean by for sweet please
let me know cuz I have no idea oh hey
are you the forcemeat can't wait to
shape you into a small role now we have
no gauge for how the size actually is so
I'm gonna do what I would assume would
just like a handful like hardy handful
of horse meat
now the moment we've all been waiting
for what the hell is that our last step
before cooking these is to wrap the
forcemeat rolls in call call is the lacy
fat that lives the organs that's what
I'm holding I have to say out of all my
years working with food this is the most
bizarre thing I have ever held just
gonna take some of this and wrap my
forcemeat roll right up yay edible
history
here we have our for prehistoric Patties
ready for frying we're gonna be frying
these at about a medium heat it doesn't
say how to fry it it just says fry and
serve I'm full repulse and in a trance
[Music]
[Applause]
and here we have it the origin of the
meat patty look at this beautiful
vaguely baked potato looking thing
doesn't make you just want to shout out
me neither
good news is though I don't have to cuz
I don't eat pork so I'm forcing our
director Matt to eat it man
look are you excited about this oh I'm
nervous yeah you're a bit to be as
historically accurate as possible you
actually have to eat it served solo
ready to go yeah go for it
here we go honestly it's not bad it's
like really really juicy
the flavor is surprisingly subtle really
there's nothing really bad about it but
feel free to just keep eating it don't
take the whole thing with me okay thank
you bye I think today we've learned not
to judge a book or a burger by its cover
no matter how odd the experience of
making that was and how odd it was to
look at it turns out it tasted pretty
good it all comes down to what's on the
inside which in this case was a series
of crushed nuts peppers and berries no
no thanks for watching this episode of
edible history what will remake next god
watch and find out